You should know, Seth, that the real
danger is Sharia law,
>> Sharia law. And you can tell when you go
to a place like Abu Dhabi or Riad, like,
oh man, I hope we don't ever wind up
with a society like this with a rape
rate of zero where you leave your keys
in your Lamborghini and don't ever worry
about it being stolen. And you know, if
people want to get wasted, they do it at
home.
Once you're in that grave, there's no I
could have, I would have, I should have
case closed. Allah tells us that a man
when he is sword is taken away Allah
says he's going to say what send me back
to do Hajj omrah salah fasting what no
sodak brothers and sisters is getting
thousands of shahadas monthly yearly
hundreds of thousands of people are
coming to Islam they are printing Quran
distributing material training duat
brothers and sisters do you want the
part of that goes on forever this is how
Islam has spread around the world
brothers and sisters carry on this
legacy of the prophetam inshallah by
donating whatever amount inshallah and
supportra right now inshallah enjoy the
video. Asalam alalaykum
brothers and sisters and dear friends
this is a video clip that came uh as you
know I don't know I didn't know Charlie
Kirk that well um and there's videos
still coming out about him. So, here's a
video of Joe Rogan and Charlie Kirk,
separate videos talking about the Sharia
law. And uh Charlie Kirk asks the
question, you know, would it would it be
better that if uh Israel or Palestine,
Israel doesn't exist if Palestine was
ruled by Muslims or Christians or Jews?
Who or Muslims or Christians? Which one
will be better for the Jews? Well, let's
find out. Let's deal with some facts.
Let's go to some history, inshallah. And
let's al watch Joe Rogan's um this might
be an old video of him talking about the
Sharia law. And you can see absolute
ignorance. Yeah. Okay. Uh let's start
with John Ro and then we'll go to
Charlie's video. Here we go.
>> Well, what's the ultimate one? The
ultimate one is Sharia law, right? The
ultimate one is bring in as many Muslims
as you can. Let them gather up steam.
Let them build up an alliance. Let let a
bunch of like really [__] stupid
wacky leftists go along with this not
knowing that that religion is counter to
everything you stand for. Yeah.
Everything you stand for as far as
women's rights, gay rights, like
religious freedom.
>> I think you're right.
>> So that's Joe Rogan's position on Sharia
Allah. I would love for someone to ask
him what does Sharia Allah mean? Can you
define it? Do you have an opinion on
civic law, common law, much less Islamic
law, nonetheless, and I've made this
point before, Muslims are never put in a
position where we can defend oursel. So
I'm going to leave it to Tucker Carlson
to defend Sharia law. Check this out.
>> So, that was a video from Joe Rogan. As
you can see, it's very ignorant. You
know, he talks about women's right.
Woman, what woman's rights are you
talking about, Joe Rogan? The fact that
they're treated like sexual objects,
like they're toilets that you can go and
uh, you know, ejaculate inside them and
just go. They're like toilets. What you
use toilet for to relieve yourself? Yes,
they've been treated like toilets. What
woman rights are you talking about?
Talking about gay rights and this that
kind of stuff. You have no idea about
the Sharia. You have no idea.
Christianity, Islam, Judaism. If your
concern is that my friend, do you know
how many Christians are there in in in
in America? Yes. People have made
Christians seem to be like some liberal
religion. My friend, they have nearly if
not they have worse like to your
definition, we believe the Quran is
perfect, but to your definition of the
Quran being bad. If that's your
criteria, if that's the yard stick, the
Bible is far far the stuff that in the
Bible, for example, raping a woman and
then you marry her by giving 50 shekels
to her father. In Islam, the man gets
the capital punishment. In the Bible,
you pay 50 shekels to get the woman. The
woman that you raped, you take her. So,
if you want to uh uh want you want a
woman, just go rape her. Interesting.
Okay. So, you have no idea what you're
talking about. Let's see what Tucker
Carlson had to say when it comes to the
Sharia. And this is a a slap in the face
of Joe Rogan and also Charlie Clerk,
which we're going to see. I hope you
guys enjoy the video, guys. But before
that, please download the Salah Pro app,
brothers and sisters. We are a charity.
All of our services on the app is for
free. Free Kiblinder. No ads, free salah
reminders, encourages to pray, tells you
salah at times. You can book a salah
instructor, a Quran instructor. You can
order a guided prayer map for absolutely
free if you want to learn how to pray
salah. Videos on how to pray salah,
salah hubs, and many, many more brother
sisters. We are not an app that shares
your information with third parties. All
of our services on the app is for free.
Download it now inshallah and enjoy.
Guys, let's go back to the video.
>> You should know, Seth, that the real
danger is Sharia law.
>> Sharia law. And you can tell when you go
to a place like Abu Dhabi.
>> Look, when he first said, I actually
thought I don't think he's been
sarcastic. I was like, "Oh god, let's
see what ignorance he has to come to
say." But look what he had to say.
Listen to it.
>> Or Riad like, "Oh man, I hope we don't
ever wind up with a society like this
with a rape rate of zero where you leave
your keys in your Lamborghini and don't
ever worry about it being stolen." And
you know, if people want to get wasted,
they do it at home. You know what I
mean?
>> Yeah. I I don't
>> Boy, I hope we don't wind up with that.
>> Mhm. Yeah. I I think that I mean Sharia
law is obviously just a punchline. I
don't know that too many people actually
believe in the reality of that and I
mean like I said you know I'm a lawyer.
I actually studied legal philosophy.
Sharia is not that different from um
other uh legal codes. Um a lot of our
own legal code the Anglo-Saxon common
law Anglo-American common law derives
ultimately from uh religious
authorities. I'll just leave it at that.
He did a pretty good job. Thanks,
Tucker. Thanks, Moana.
>> This is the laws that people lived by
for centuries. You've come with your new
liberal and you don't even like the you
don't even like the left. You don't even
know what you want. You say you're
right, conservative, you know, but then
that's like closer to the Sharia, but
then you're like, "No, no, we don't want
the Sharia." So, what the hell do you
want? You don't like the left. Okay,
Sharia law is too for too much for you.
What the hell do you want? You don't
even know what you want. But anyways,
let's go to a video of Charlie Kirk old
video. Let's see what he had to say
because it seems like he's ve he was
very ignorant and I believe he was
brainwashed and he was waking up to that
reality towards the end of his life.
That's why Israel assassinated him and
killed him and Candace Owens debunks
this you know shows the reality and
follow it in but here's a video.
>> Do you think that it's better for
Christianity to have Israel controlled
by Jews or Israel controlled by Muslims?
>> Part of my family is from Tan. They're
Iranian Muslim.
>> No, they are Christian. They are
Armenian.
>> So that's interesting. See, you see how
he's like, "Yeah, I know what you're
talking about. Sh." Oh. Oh, they're Oh,
oh, they're Oh, they're Christian. Oh,
okay. You see the ignorance. It's
actually He doesn't know. He didn't
know. You can see the utter ignorance.
Look at the reaction. Oh. Oh. Okay.
Let's carry on.
>> They've lived in town their entire life.
There's a big community and they have
churches that they go every single
Sunday. They are proud of who they are.
They wear their crosses out. Not a
problem. But let's go talk about like
let's talk about Egypt, Syria, Jordan.
They have thousands of churches there.
They have big Christian faith over
there. But they are Muslim majority
countries and run by Muslims and the
churches are protected.
>> There you go. So the question he asked
is it better that it is run by the
Christians or the Muslims? Well, if it
means better that the Christians will
massacre the Jews, which they did in
history when Saladun Aubi when he
conquered Jerusalem, okay, and he gave
amnesty to those hostile individuals,
okay, who left, they were individuals.
He had to bring family members, okay, he
he made it open. When the Muslims
conquered those lands, they made sure
the Jews were living there, the
Christians were living there, the
Muslims were living there peace by um
side by side in peace. That's the reason
why before Palestine was con occupied,
the Jews, the Christians and the Muslims
live there for centuries of peace.
There's churches there till this day.
But I thought our religion teaches that
we have to kill the infidors wherever
you see them. Bizarre. When it
conquered, when Islam, Islamic Empire
conquered
Egypt. Yes, you see there are Coptic
Christians there for centuries. And this
found something very beautiful you would
not even uh maybe not even realize. You
see the crown jewels and all the stuff
in the British Museum etc that was
stolen by certain lands and brought back
and the the crown jewels that the queen
used to wear. Yes, they were stolen.
It's very interesting when the Islamic
Empire conquered needed a whole the
parts of the world. Nothing was brought
back to Mecca. You don't find the crown
jewels and Mecca and stolen artifacts
here and there because Islam wherever it
went it uplifted that nation. That's why
you see it didn't even in Egypt it
didn't even harm the mummified uh
things. Even though with us is it's like
it can be deemed as idol worship. They
did not touch it. So subhan Allah and
there's so many examples in history. For
example, when Omar the secondh after
Omar Abu Bakr when he went and conquered
Jerusalem, the Christians used to
desecrate the Jewish temples and places
there and they kic they they they did
not want the Jews to be there. Who
brought 40 Jewish families? Yes. To live
in Jerusalem in uh in Palestine? The
Muslims. Yes. The Muslims protected them
so much. There was a rabbi who said, "If
the Muslims were ruling, yes, at the
time of Hitler, we would have 6 million
extra Jews alive today." Yes. So, you
can see clearly and categorically.
Tucker Carson is waking up to this
reality as you can see. And it's people
don't understand. They've been so damn
brainwashed. What law? You agree with
Sharia law? If only you understood it.
Yes. What is your punishment? I've said
this before in the liberal warview. What
is your punishment, man, for rapists?
people who go and that innocent
Ukrainian girl who ran from war torn air
zone goes to America gets stabbed
senselessly on a train looking
horrified. What should be the punishment
for that person? That person was a
repeat offender. What does Islam done?
Do it does it takes them to the chop
chop square. Chop chop mate. Chop chop.
Get rid of them. No. Using my tax payer
money to give them nice hot food, hot
bed, hot shower, uh you know, nice uh
AC, PlayStation, read books, have fun.
You know, you just murdered murdered
someone for no reason. You live your
life m and we'll pay for it. We the
innocent will pay for it. In Islam, it
says having mercy on the corporate is on
the innocent. That's why in Islam
there's a capital punishment to
individuals like this. And let me tell
you something. Most of you guys agree
with that unless you're a lefty. Okay?
Most of you far right, you agree with
that. Okay? Let me tell you something.
There will be thousands of less pedos,
white middle-aged men and women, okay?
who will be roaming the streets with our
taxpayers money sending them to prison.
Okay, there'll be less much of them and
tax tax money would go to somewhere more
useful uh you know to the victims more
like than the culprits and there were
less moles walking around on the streets
of the UK and America. So hope this is a
reminder to you guys in if you look into
the Sharia the Sharia defended the
Christians and the Jews against the
tyranny of others and fought them and
that's the reason why they used to pay
jiza because that was their protection.
Subhan Allah. And if the Muslim armies,
if I'm not mistaken, I don't know if it
was Mawa. Yes. Once they went to defend
a specific Christian group against
another Christian denomination and they
couldn't, you know what they did? They
came back and gave them the Jizian
money. They said, "Because this money
was given to us to protect you, we
couldn't fulfill that. Here is your
money back." That is how just they were.
And that's why the West makes you fear
the Sharia and Muslims because we are
the only ones standing against their
satanic satanic uh evil demonic
lifestyle and their worldview. And they
they are the ones behind Israel. These
Zionist dirt bags who are behind they're
the biggest anti-semites. JFK
assassination, Liberty, US, USS Liberty
who which got attacked the 9/11 Charlie
Kirk. They are behind it all. The
laughing Zionist. Yeah. Okay. You can't
make this up guys. Anyways, brother and
sisters, it's been a pleasure. Till next
time. Asalam alaikum.
We're better cat.